تحول دراماتيكي للاحداث لاكبر شركه
اعلاميه في العالم تاثيرها على الاطفال
قبل الكبار شركه ديزني العالميه قالت
رئيسه تنفيذي بوب تشابك واعلنت انها اعاده
رئيسه تنفيذيه السابق بوب ايجار لتولي
الزمام الامور مجددا خلف مسرح الاقاله في
ديزني الكثير من الكواليس الظاهر منها
اقاله المدير السابق للخسائر الماديه
الكبيره التي سقطت فيها الشركه كثيرون
ارجعوا وعدم القدره على تحقيق ارباح الى
دخول ديزني في جبل واشكاليات حول العالم
بسبب اعتماد اجنده مثيره للجدل خاصه في
الشرق الاوسط حيث منع الدول العرض اعمالها
المتهممه بالترويج للمثليه هناك في الغرب
ايضا من انقلب على ديزني حيث هو اظهرت
دراسه حديثه اجرتها شركه ترافال جار انا
ما يصل الى 70% من الامريكيين يعارضون جدا
ديزني هذا انت غالبا ما توضع في اطار ما
يعرف بثقافه الواوك
[موسيقى]
المشهد الاعلامي الامريكيه يمر على ما
يبدو في مرحله تغييرات جديده وتحدثنا عن
ديزني والمحتوى الترفيهي وسنتحدث الان عن
سي ان ان والمحتوى الاخباري الرئيس الجديد
للشبكه الاخباريه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الشبكه
الاخباريه الاولى في الولايات المتحده
وجدت بحسب تحليلات نشرتها الصحف الامريكيه
ان الجنوح الى اليسار افقدها موقعها
الاكثر اهميه وربما اكثر ربحيه في الوسط
الرئيس الجديد يرى بانه يتعين على الشبكه
ان تبقى وافيه لفكرتها الرئيسيه وهي ان
الخبر هو النجم وليس الراي ولابد من
الخروج من تركه حكم ترامب العاصفه ولو ان
ترامب ربما يعود
لكن هذا الراي ليس الراي الوحيد على
الطاوله كثيرون يعتقدون بان مكان الوسط في
مجتمع منقسم ليس هناك جمهور في المنتصف
بحسب ذلك الراي الاخر
مقدمه برنامج من المصدر المتخصص بوسائل
الاعلام في قناه العربيه جيلان اهلا بك
نورتنا في صباح العربيه طيب
ديزني المحتوى الترفيه الى السي ان
والمحتوى الاخباري شهدنا في الفتره هذه
تغييرات كبيره في المشهد مشهد الاعلام
الامريكي حدثيني اولا عن اسبابها اول شيء
سنحكي عن الابرز التغيرات التي طرات في
كبرى المؤسسات الاعلاميه الامريكيه التي
تسمى
ميديا والتي غالبا ما تتبع التيار
الليبرالي وتميل اكثر الى الحزب
الديمقراطي شهدت في الفتره الاخيره سلسله
من التغيرات في الشكل والمضمون بعد ان
غازل في فتره طويله الوك كالشر او التي
يعني تميل
للمتطرف او اليسار لبلال المتطرف والذي
الاغلبيه في الجمهور الامريكي لا يميل الى
هذه
هذا التيار الفكري المتطرف لذلك الان نشهد
سلسله من التغيرات في هذه قبل المؤسسات
الاعلاميه الامريكيه ابرز في الشكل
والمضمون نرى في مثلا في ام بي سي هناك
مغادره لمذيعه اشتهرت بعدائها للجمهوريين
واتهمت بانها عنصريه حتى اتجاه البيض وهي
تفني اقراص وايضا في تي في سي ان بي سي
نرى ان تشربرد
ازيح عن الشاشه
بسبب ارائها السياسيه وقالت الشركه انه
ازيح لان الشركه تريد التركيز اكثر على
الجانب الاقتصادي والابتعاد عن السياسه
لكن كبر التغيرات حصلت في السي ان ان عند
استلام
لقياده المحطه او رئاسه المحطه لو اعلن
انه يريد استعاده الحياه والموضوعيه الى
هذه
مسلسل العريقه تايم جيلان برنامجك من
المصدر الذي يعرض كل يوم جمعه على شاشه
العربيه هو مبني على البحث فيما يتم
تداوله من ملفات على وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه اليوم اذا هذه المساله ما هي
الدوافع
دوافع وراء هذه التغييرات هو طبعا اول شيء
هناك تراجع في ثقه الجمهور بمصداقيه تلك
المؤسسات همم مركز الابحاث في قال ان
جمهور الامريكي ما عدا يثق بهذه المؤسسات
العريقه في وسائل الاعلام لكن طبعا ليس هو
هذا السبب الرئيسي وراء كل تلك التغيرات
السبب الرئيسي ماده نرى ان همم الاعلام
همم لبرالي يسقط كثير من جمهوره الوسط
وبالتالي يفقد الاعلانات والممولين طبعا
الاموال بالمؤسسات التي لها باع كبير
وجمهور كبير كبير مثلا
رفضت عدم مشاهدينا 27% وللسنه الاولى منذ
سنوات طويله انخفض مردود المالي لسي ان ان
اقل من مليار دولار وهذا ماستر عن انتباه
يعني القيميين عاده هذه المحطه وهي رضوان
الاستحواذ الفئه الوسطيه او الجمعه حتى
الجمهوريين يريدون استقطابهم من جديد مع
كلاش الاستقطاب الحاد في البلاد في
الولايات المتحده ويريدون طبعا تعرفون انا
الثقافه التلفزيونات في المطاعم والمقاه
هي الثقافه يعني همم كبيره وتريد ان ان
تعود في خلفيه جميع الشاشات في تلك
طيب
اعاده موضوع السياسي لاسباب ماليه كما قلت
هل وكيف يمكن النصيب بشكل عام اليوم
المشهد الاعلامي
بعد الانتخابات النصفيه ظهرت
همم فوز او الاستطلاعات الراي لان الشعب
الامريكي سائما من اخبار ترامب والتركيز
عن ترامب ويريد الاخبار الحقيقيه واخفت
حده الاستقطاب في البلاد وعليا القنوات
التليفزيونيه تبعت هذا المزاج العام في
البلاد فماذا ان سي ان ان يعني تخلصت من
البروز من الوجوه الاعلاميه المستفزه
للجمهوريه
وابرزهم برانزستور
وايضا نرى ان في في البوكس نيوز الجمهوريه
ايضا بدات هناك بدات الانتقادات تظهر تجاه
ترامب وهذه ظاهره مستجده في هذه القناه
يعني حتى بيقولوا انه مرات صار في شويه
تحول حتى مثلا فرنسيه الان ما كان فين
انتقادات الديمقراطيين مؤخرا بدات تطفو
على السطح ما قالت تنتقل ديمقراطيه مثلا
في سي ان على كل حال احنا بنشكرك على كل
هذه المعلومات
المشاهدين تابعوا برنامج من المصدر على
شاشه العربيه كل يوم جمعه الفطيره اي ساعه
تمانيه ونص بتوقيت دبي حتى اكد شكرا جيلان
شكرا